welcome to this video a 15-minute game
again against Enrique booty in the
liquor booty let's check this is not the
Netherlands right there is some mmm yeah
there's some South American like like
Paraguay or something it is Paraguay Wow
then I got it right okay um okay but
should come down this is still some
chest to be played guessing the flag is
not a point okay but what could I do
here maybe the Queen's indian from in
just for just to get some variety in III
m this is not bad at all oftentimes
caught the classical variation it's um
it's not played so often for no
particular reason it's some quite
interesting Black has many options the
main line is to play d5 can also give
this check just not bad the c5 I maybe
give that check let's see you it's got
Bishop T to 92 93 there or nan King
moves have been played yet well not ft 2
looks crazy but an ID bd2 is probably
the the most ambitious move
all this one yeah obviously this now
leads to a position typical of the NIMS
oh there is 94 here and then it can
castle for porn sack or Quincy to both
interesting job I don't really know this
this line but okay it should be possible
to to play without knowing every every
nook and cranny of this okay yeah now
Bishop takes and f5 is right if I'm not
just taken
our castles and then probably move like
night to you wanna maybe but okay I
can't cancel this shouldn't be bad at
all yeah so what's my plan young there's
there's a very straightforward plan
interesting yeah which is rook f6 route
h6 clean edge for flying plane for
checkmate org h6 g6 but he's attacking
my nightie immediately question is yeah
yeah I should probably take it I don't
or queen edge foyer maybe queen edge for
is not so stupid if he goes g3 this also
that's even the captcha on the two
because of night f4d for tactics okay
maybe do that G so G 393 rg3 is not
possible than even okay if it takes with
the night I'm taking with the bishop and
something like knight takes Bishop takes
Bishop takes Queen takes Queen takes f
takes e4 should be should be really good
young I have 96 a five at the end of
this line so we cannot simply trade our
own pieces trading is not really invites
favor anyway so on f3 looks normal and
then the question is do I just take on
or do I play Knight g5
keeping pieces on ignite g5 and then
intend a look f 6 g cof 6 h-6 after all
yeah good move good move i think mmm
yeah do I take or not
hmm yeah i'm unsure to be honest move
like 95 can easily lead to a position
where my pieces are stepping on each
other's toes on the other hand okay I
don't want to waste more time here this
is also an issue let's discuss a move
that costs time yeah 96 was mine my
intentions connects looks after d5 I
have 95 so this is not not a threat down
a very good day I might manage Knight a5
bishop asics playing against the c-4
pond but this certainly needs some some
help by white yeah this was of course
possible opening opening the position up
Jim not clear to me I probably need to
take
yeah well II five looks like the most
obvious reply I'm unsure though about
possible c5 ever d 4 hangs him okay the
other nurses any five is probably
correct yeah the rooks are connected
this is was one point of playing 96 but
now to a five or is this it is not not
right
hmm yeah this also is this could be
offside this piece maybe just night here
to e7 and possibly regroup it later yeah
long-term I have some chances against
his pawns but short-term the bishop on
b7 is just biting on the d5 pawn it's
not so clear how to how to make any
progress here maybe white can even play
yeah maybe can do that looks like we
need for just attacking d7 how do I
protect that they're not easy not so
easy yeah temper at least temporarily
I'm not very well coordinated
yeah he found it he has found it that's
a good move how do I protect the pawn
yeah this also takes a fade
now that's it's really uncomfortable
maybe I can maybe I need to do something
really strange looking like rook f.2d 8
and d6 Bishop c 8p should be seven
something like that okay if I go 26 27
that's already already already rather
rather uncomfortable covering it with
Fuji for just runs into h3 and deserve
okay not that I like to play that he
just has rook f2 now on look at three
doubling on the F file
yeah Queen fo was strong maybe maybe I
really should have played 95 in this
case on a move like we need for I could
just retreat to e7 enter and nothing
much is happening ok d6 rook h3 is not
the problem i can go to i can go to f6
look everyone now no I thought Bishop c8
and Bishop here
and looks it is a somewhat shaky
position in it I have a slightly a bit
back rank I don't know it looks like
there might be something for him if I go
Bishop d7 that's also the additional
problem of Queen a six maybe I need to
play even a five and then the should be
seven at least with bishop CA T cannot
play book h3 anymore
you know you can go to have seven young
but I'm not sure that this threatens
much g 3m threatens g3
I go to g7 Bishop d7 Queen 86 maybe have
a perpetual with Bishop see aid or let's
say repetition perpetual as mostly
referring to checks you know maybe maybe
do that and see if you really goes to a
6 Queen a 3 maybe now but Queen a 6 is
the most most logical way to play I
thought I can just play Bishop back to
see eight and then reconsider what what
I should do this is just hoping that he
goes somewhere else
yeah you should detect the a pawn keep a
detect with Queen a six maybe queen a
three yeah after we move I need to I
need to address the g3 idea after Queen
a3 I can I can just just play rook e8
maybe but Queen 86 looks like the most
obvious move what else
nope that's like that's a that's too
passive I believer in him so what what
is my plan what's my plan g3 if I go
look he aids to cover I'm not really I
wait I can play rock yet anyway this is
not bad I can I can play Queen to h5
like g3 tweenage 5 threatening Queen f7
and I need to get the rooks of he
obviously the rooks here on the flr a
very annoying and one possible way would
be queen age 5 intending to take f7 he
moves the rock back and then look fa to
exchange I have some chances for active
play in the end game I have a and have a
very neat pawn structure without any
weaknesses love white has of course the
double porn and he also has a potential
weakness on a form the c-4 pawn just
imagine a night going over to f6 the
bishop to g6 this pawn can get under
pressure it's not likely that you will
lose it but it's still still a weakness
yes so crew in here to attack the rook
I'm a between F 2 hmm
yes a move it is a move hmm yeah yeah
it's not threatening something yet but
yeah I need to get get this rock out of
my cam can I do that not easy baby is no
maybe here
I don't think he's really threatening
anything maybe I'm wrong with he is
threatening something I Queen have to
wear that was so what was a strong
maneuver
hmm
my DM was tuned to secure the back rank
and possibly possibly bring the knight
to f6 am King King King away and the
night f6 yeah the night I cannot move it
at the moment because these seven Hanks
maybe I should have played rookie aid
yeah before I was hanging but hey I I
don't know takes Queen f6 and this is at
least draw and probably it's more
hmm I wonder I wonder if Bishop g fries
and is a moose he has the bad bishop but
it's also the bishop that protects the
pawns and i don't i don't know maybe
maybe it's a good idea to exchange those
i'm unsure this tries to prepare that
like Bishop g4 takes Queen takes and
then night g6 Andrew Kuwait this is what
I'd like to do and it's not easy to
accomplish
if I this listen this really makes
Bishop g4 much more attractive yeah I
don't know I'm always a bit afraid that
I'm missing a tactic the rook on f7 all
this is really a bit shaky for me yes we
can to the home this is surprising can I
go what if I go Bishop h5 bishop age
five trying to take it where does it go
it's a bit weird but where does it go
and threatening Queen f7 now I think it
only has a three by five yeah that's in
fact not so easy okay I need to take now
I'm threatening a form and Bishop g4
maybe should be four white resigns why
oh come on why spoil this game by just
resigning what did I overlooked
something easy
I don't think so on it's yes I've won an
exchange but it's not it's not entirely
clear I mean how do I win the special
Bonnie for is not bad I mean it it has
some let's put it on the board it has
some effect here not on b6 but on c6
nope here cannot so easily play the C
porn and how do i actually get get get
to get ahead here it's not so easy yeah
why did you resign mysterious oops I'm
sorry yeah I've known no clear-cut way
to to open the position for the rooks I
can move like that it's not helping me
you can even play here the problem is
after King g3 what am i doing if I play
h5 for example he has Bishop f Bishop g5
and I'm not sure if I'm even better how
do I win the snow he has this as the
right in at the right moment it's not
clear I mean he blundered the exchange
but it's not like he's losing instantly
h5 is a bad idea though if I ever play
move like that then this is the problem
yeah I need to remove it and then maybe
here even attending attending g4
maybe maybe I can Bishop g4s probably
nonsense anyway probably what I need to
do is something like that Bishop here
and then c6 to get it open yeah this is
the right one but he does not need to
resign I mean you can fight on here no
one no reason to to resign here at this
particular stage hmm yeah that's a comp
very complicated came and he had a
really nice position I'm probably here I
need to do something else computer wants
to do now g 6 cm yeah and then this is
probably just quick on ah no that's the
idea I'm sorry that's the idea much much
better than my plan I need to get rid of
the rook if the rook needs to retreat
that everything's then everything's fine
for black yeah that's that's a good idea
I didn't see the idea to go to h eight
and this this is problematic due to what
he played this is now really bit shaky
the computer recommends this one and
then aged 4 oops no queen e r3 and gifts
gives wider a very substantial edge stop
fishes on + 3 i'm not quite sure why i
mean i understand that he has pressure
but what exactly is the threat in this
position
I'm sorry I don't understand the threat
what is so terrible yeah I mean I know
pressure and everything but what why am
I losing routine I don't see why I don't
heed yes he does not have a sacrifice or
something the computer wants to play
Queen g5 Bishop d1 and then h 5 which is
completely ridiculous why do I do that
or is it type of zoosk one that I don't
have ever having muth right I wanted to
do something like this here an IG eight
bit of edge form that's the problem ah
yeah okay that's indeed more than a
problem yeah then I'm lost basically so
he should have played this should be too
so what what does this mean this was
probably means i need to go here to UM
to be on the square yeah but okay I'm in
bad shape I had the suspicion during the
game of course but i didn't i didn't see
how I lose and he didn't really have a
didn't really have a good idea here
Bishop g4s the comp move him now now
again Queen f3 was good ah here yet a
tactical stroke not that one this leads
to good play okay but he could have
taken and taken him okay this is the
idea
hmm yeah rook g3 that's not nice at all
now maybe ruka ATM okay but this could
also this one check check check
hmm yeah mm-hmm I'm just trying to
figure out if this is just a loss or
black care has some fighting chances the
depth the issue could be that it is
somewhat closed of course as position
and whites rook is somewhat lost in my
camp I'm not sure how it should precede
it might go here but let's say something
like that maybe i can i can try
something like that yeah why this of
course very close to winning not sure if
you should win but yeah he played this
some very interesting they were
interesting what what exactly was the
problem here Queen a form of course the
computer wants to play technically
Quincy form now just protecting like
that but it looks shaking now I'm the ID
of like 1g form but this seems to lead
to trouble yeah and I mean this this was
of course um and even more serious issue
probably this is some even better yeah
yeah so I it seems that I must do
something else iam so young if I'd is
not necessarily a threat maybe it's a
matter of precise move orders a move
like that for example this fits into the
general structure
and blood and just asked white one what
he is doing next this whole Queen a for
business was also a problem because it
was attacking this pawn and so it's a
technical thing if he loses some time oh
yeah I can even just just exchanged
looks young yeah yeah this is much
better yeah much madam so if I've is a
mistimed move I don't really have
alternative see I can go to a five but
this is an issue of with this move is
that c5 is a possibility and what now if
I take it this is just gone yrc for so
what's also good I cannot so this is why
Knight a5 is not great and two outs I
mean cannot really go back to the eighth
or something I mean yeah and then really
Queenie form yeah yeah if no good move I
feel good move yep it's um it's tricky
yeah this is the comp idea playing like
that which looks completely completely
strange yeah he's got computer wants to
do wants to play that def completely
completely impossible for a human to to
get this idea even it's assessing this
is equal by the way okay yeah an
interesting game thanks for watching